yeah that's something the Kraken we're talking
about this morning as well they need to stop
this downward spiral they're in right now and
start to put some wins together turn over to
Quick chance and Skinner robs Oliver Bor Strand
and you'll recall Louie Newen Hopkins gliding
through a cc D Newan Hopkins cers and that was
nearly stuffed home by K but the save made by
Joey and bring it into the games and there's
another one by col in a blocken and is down off
that Rocket 88 milph off the Stick of the E nurse
Sam G who has the B bottled up initially by danana
Kane fired it across to Matas e who replac boar a
cloud across a shot save the s went for wber shot
lson do not make it through that one caught Bard
in the KN spot here's D find MC David he's in Back
Store goals and backto back games for MC David
it's one nothing for the Oilers and that's how
this starts it's Larson that zipper right there
is handled in front of the net in the battle
and on the transitional play here it is dry cidal
beautiful back pass the streaking McDavid once he
puts it in high gear his head's up the whole time
and the patient backhand move as he just fakes a
shot to courts down and he just kind of wraps it
around him tucks it into the net no chance you're
catching him on that play and sometimes you do
get quiet on that bench it's hard to kind of pull
yourself out of it but so important to keep that
confidence it's a wonderful thing when you have
it and you can sense they're starting to feel it
that way again bers with the strip on Fogle dring
the other way Everly a sh rebound score and Jared
mccan has tied it for Seattle yeah he was due got
a piece of this one good activation here to get
up the Rush by alexc dishit wide and then funnel
to the net it's Everly just kind of chops that
through and it does go off the paddle of Skinner
and it actually Ricochet is off of Manan gets
his stick down he's in a battle all the way back
to the net and goes off the shin pad they don't
ask you how and that ties the game and for Jared
mccan he's had a little bit of trouble putting the
puck in the back of the net pointless here's the
amamoto s in deep NE go da able to [Music] reverse
Bard tried to Fish It Up done a snap shot K home
Seattle has its first lead two to one it looks
like Belmar in front got a piece of this one
Jack on the quick rer by Dunn come up with a loose
puck right here this Puck's on the stick of buar
but he's out mused by Yamamoto and it's the second
man cier that just digs this one out of that pile
puts it back but it's the quick shot of done watch
how quickly this is off ftic it's a bouncing Puck
and he just Corrals and Zips it to the net on the
rer and Belmar in front watch this direction right
there so steuart skinners got that shot back
after the goal by the David with two goals in
a span of 204 chipped up the right hand side by
dban now you've got Yanni Gore waiting dishing
back what timer Schultz made rebound and Skinner
a left P denial of Tolman who was prone himself
come in with a record of 49 and one looking for
a third consecutive Victory Seattle looking to
avoid a third straight loss Alex wide open front
shot Adam lson sto by SK right to force me it to
bork Strand and that was intercepted by E Edington
in transition D makes one move a shot made rebound
Ernie tried to back it off the court thre it in
Fr H can't finish Seattle two Edon one fin three
minutes here in the second period a swing game
for both hocket clubs shot from the point save
made rebound score and there's goal number one
on the season for Alex W ber the Kraken lead by
a deuce Monday versus Colorado got taken away for
goalie interference but this time off the cycle
left there a couple great chances at the other end
of cor with a couple great saves it's wber on some
nice work to get him this Puck and he makes a good
move in tight he gets lost in coverage Ducks back
to the net and then just tucks it back around
and now it's McDavid building speed through the
neutral zone Seattle collapsing McDavid forced
out wide tan couldn't sneaking past at home down
low for Evander Kane off the boards BLK make the
onetime by Evander Kane and it right back in this
game it's three to2 on Kane's fifth of the year
not maybe being hard enough on the goal against
in the corner defensively but offensively a
terrific job the rush up the ice by McDavid
put it into high gear walks around everyone this
slopper right here fake walk and find the Stick
of Kane for the redirection and Evander Kane gets
himself to the front of the net once he makes this
play that'll duck inside all alone he gets lost
and all he needs to do is redirect this one onto
the net beautiful shot pass right there by buard
and it's a one goal game and the Oilers have life
Schwarz sends one off the board Skinner will jab
at it Belmar first on the puff we're down to 2
minutes left to play in Seattle playing keep away
Tolen in a shot save Skinner a degree on that one
tolven and jumps into that spot picks his side
a wing or win they'll need a big draw here from
drle drle Powers through flattens Belmar here's
Bard dishing off Newen Hopkins KS it down little
thr The Equalizer of entertain three all they
were I when this Puck went in the net but here
it is here face off Wi that's where they thought
maybe a face a penalty was in the mix by dry as
he keeps his stick down on Belmar and Belmar right
beside me is having some words with everybody on
the Everton bench once again but it was dryy that
holds him down finds the puck makes a OneTouch
pass right through a knuckler that finds the
stick of EV andri Kan fans on the first one but
shovels home this Tri wants a change Bard the
hand off and McDavid knows he's got two fresh
bodies coming off Newen Hopkins and nurse McDavid
right around B to the and that stayed out here's
Jordan Everly down the right hand side Newen
hopkins's good friend forces a bad pass here's
Newen opkins for viory wde Rebound Conor mcdavis
and trying to complete a comeback with 31 down
with six and a half to go nurse to McDavid LS it
back McDavid shoots save aord and he'll elect to
fall on it with nurse turning up the pressure
hman waiting protecting and now blar wide open
hman King the timer score the entrance is
the winner Ed for Seattle three in over
time Evan buard all over the ice on this play
Hing with some strong work stay in the Hut move
your feet take the puck one pass Beautiful
One by Hing over the cave and he puts it
upstairs on De cord took them some time they
finally figured him out the urgency went up
and they started to make plays and it pays
off with a huge win as EV came looks to the
sky the seventh hatrick of his NHL career
completes an unlikely TW goal rally with 6 and
a half to go Kane is fifth sixth and seventh goals
of the year he ties it with 45 seconds to go and
he wins it with 203 left at OT the Edmonton Oilers
four the Seattle Kraken three and overtime H drama